[inaudible]
on Google B.
or what I was in education.
all we use is go right so. I don't.
I've been worried that my boyfriend is going to be there.
[INAUDIBLE]
We are multi-bakeles of the time of the movie.
(electronic music)
>> No, you're good.
I'm actually good.
getting ready to get my car to head to the airport.
So if you hear what your voice is.
We're good.
I'm going to get you a bit of a stop.
I know that where you part of the wall, you part of the wall.
So, kind of my arm was just because of my arm.
I feel that I go off. So.
And it's not really on my idea, dude.
like my, my, my, my, my. (indistinct)
[ Inaudible ]
[inaudible]
So, you can see the idea.
[ Pause ]
I think that I want to come out.
[inaudible]
but
I like the idea of saying me and investing my destiny.
better. I like what you said. So let's go with that. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
trying to anyway. It doesn't always work out that way.
But so tell me about about you. It's been a minute or
What are you doing now?
[LAUGHTER]
Awesome.
That's a question that I get from my...
family quite often is you're making all this much
for someone else. Have you ever thought about what I had on your own?
and I'm like, "Mmm, yes and no."
know because oftentimes people don't understand.
how much goes into all of that and all those.
but also kudos to you
because I think that's a fantastic journey.
Like you have a talent.
that I think is definitely in that realm of...
possibility to be able to support multiple
disciplines not just the janitorial
space or what have you. So yeah.
That's awesome. Yeah.
(upbeat music)
(mumbling)
[inaudible]
It's interesting because I feel like...
When we worked together, it was in a time where...
I was really gaining my footing and learning the business.
itself, right? And I think I had a couple people...
throughout that really helped me learn which you were one of
those key people in the very beginning for me for sure.
And we kind of joke about it now where Sean.
Henderson somewhat hid me from the cease-
from Charles specifically, right?
the first year and a half because
I want you to find a key. What you do.
find someone who's driven.
They're all similar, right?
Espionage probably not.
outside of the norm from the facilities group or ABM.
When you find people who are driven, they tend to like it.
Lacton and Pylon and...
Promote you very quickly and then...
expectations come very quickly.
I was thankful that he hid me for enough.
So at least an year and a half record
learned the business side of it.
But also smart enough to know
where my resources lie, my proposal
>> [INAUDIBLE]
The Rotary Key Player from the beginning that helped me understand
>> Thank you.
Can you help me understand?
Because I think that's where
But that's what's helped me kind of look off in some of this.
Building relationships first.
I think when we say that.
see people who come and we've recently hired quite a few people.
you'll notice on our LinkedIn from Amazon.
And it's important to have a...
on your own.
[INAUDIBLE]
Thanks, and then you combine them and...
I really don't have the power to go through the truth.
[INAUDIBLE]
[inaudible]
I think that's a good piece for me.
and where I'm at today.
I am managing this. I am managing this.
We're going to roll again into jail our relationship, which is...
I will last year.
I've been promoting that role for the past year and I've declined.
Because you're not.
So, we're not making sure.
[INAUDIBLE]
We also had a surrounding of people who
So, you know, this week can make a break.
Somebody, and I think...
I think that there's a couple, you know, there's people in there who are...
support of their people who are. I know Charles did one that's
very high stress, very passionate, I should say that.
his business.
I think some of that is can you take
[inaudible]
So that's what I'm still learning.
this new role, which is really that different.
from other roles other than I now have a man.
[INAUDIBLE]
[inaudible]
>> I'm sorry.
Yeah, I think it was. It's not that it was a sinking ship.
We're in a better spot with you.
than we've ever been in the good.
spot because Sean's really spent a lot of time developing that
relationship. I truly believe that we
We didn't have someone in the--
who could dedicate enough time to building those relationships.
internally with them.
transactional, severe, and more relationship focused.
And so it's really trying to find out.
what makes them tick, what their goals are.
And we had, you know, we went through
in the past two years, quite a few.
players, which also lends jail out to
think that this role is a little unstable.
[INAUDIBLE]
My hope is that this was interesting already.
That's not what we have to do.
and kind of how to do it.
But on the same thing.
time I was still when I say
So learning the business, right?
[INAUDIBLE]
[inaudible]
I was in the light on fire.
Great question.
Um, I, I think we're.
What I have for me is
The one thing that maybe I'm bringing to the table is
someone else didn't, like my predecessor would be.
Just the sheer time.
that it takes into and I set some
clear boundaries when I took this role, right? Not necessarily like
Not necessarily like even work-life balance.
Boundaries it was if I'm gonna take this for one
It's going to be successful here are some things that I need.
And I need to--
to be behind like I need to be able to build a team. I don't want to.
to play past the trash. Don't give me all of your account directors.
who failed another area. You're looking for a place for them to land.
because they have family safety like I need.
I need to be able to have full discretion on my
team and how I build it.
They agree to that.
to me being able to
just get in front of as many people as I want to.
So.
I think there's some freedom there that maybe wasn't.
And like when Dustin Smith was in charge of this.
role. He was a lot of what he had was very administrative.
He was spending so much time on his reports.
and the callouts and the pipeline and developing
all these like imaginary numbers to put in front of Charles.
that there was no really meat on the bone for him.
Right, so when I'm okay, that's great. You have, you know, 10 million.
your pipeline. Are those going to close this year? We'll probably
not because we don't even they're just like ideas floating around we heard this
might come out to ROP.
So I tried to--
be very also.
realistic with the team insane. Here's what I'm doing.
hearing, but we have zero relationships here.
So my goal is to get in front, find them right.
decision makers or the influencers get in front of them.
be able to tell you what the probability is because I'm not going to tell you
that just because we're a partner with JLL that are
the probability of us winning that is high because we know that's not how it works.
So that's where I think.
Honestly, I had to set myself up for 7-0.
[INAUDIBLE]
And if you're not willing to allow me to do that, I don't want the role.
because it would be successful at that point.
So,
in my eyes, maybe someone else could,
but the way I, the way I,
I would run it. This is how I see it and I feel like...
between Nicole and Sean.
right now and even Nick McMackins they've given me
kind of a they've been really good about introducing
to people right now to get me in front of people.
so that I can kind of be seen as that decision maker, but
also allowing me to build
the team. So there's been a couple people that I that I tried to plug.
And obviously there's
to push back, right?
Like, oh my gosh, that's a key player for my vertical.
That's a key player.
player for my account and understood.
with all we have are five key players in the whole company.
Then--
We're in bigger trouble than we thought.
So yeah, I think that's my strength.
It's just--
honestly learning that I can't do it all. I have to
the right people around me. So hopefully that's
going to show. Hopefully that will be successful this year. We'll see.
It's early.
It's still Sean.
I mean, I probably talked in a cold more than I do Sean now.
from a growth standpoint.
but technically I reported the Sean.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
Yep.
I hope so.
my fingers across.
Mm-hmm.
Hmm. Um.
I don't know if...
there that I feel that there is a blocker for me.
internally. Yeah, I don't know that I do
feel like we're in a good spot on this
team right now whether it be on the IFM side like whether we see various
I think we've built out a team.
on both sides where
We do see a lot of support even from C-suite.
There's a lot of support as far as.
how we are managing the growth.
There's obviously still a lot of pressure to
grow right and some pretty intense growth
targets but that's not changed.
but I think what's maybe a little bit different is
It's really, we really have restructured quite a bit,
whether it's
on the R&D side to--
We sold our same C-suite key players, right, Val and Nicole.
And we've had a couple CR...
and you know that kind of thing.
of stuff but at the end of the day
The people who really close the deals are not your C-suite people.
anyway. They're just not. Now they might...
They might, because they have so much historical knowledge,
like in the coming months.
Nicole will remember a deal from 15 years ago.
So remember with the exact revenue amount, so remember how many heads.
and all the crazy data behind it, it's crazy.
But so she can give me an idea who I
I need to get in front of and who those decision makers are.
But at the end of the day--
I don't know that Val
is responsible for closing the door.
any of the deals. She's kind of that that
person on the backside once we've closed the deal, how do we retain the
work on those contractor knows because
to make sure that the operational pieces are running smoothly.
But as far as like growing and
the pipeline and and what I mean
all of it I guess is now my responsibility whether it's the
the growth or the operational piece to make sure that
We retain our growth and our in this article, but.
I do believe that we have like we really kind of
segregated off now where I felt like when I first started to make it was
because I was naive to it.
It was really messy.
Like everyone.
Everybody's hand was in the cookie jar for everything.
was on a pricing call. That was on the pricing call. She had her say
Todd had his say Nicole had her say
You know what I mean?
And so now we're in a good spot where--
if it's sales, it's the Meenakal Shon.
on and the pricing team.
If it's operation.
Val's involved, Scott Idens involved, Roger Downmont.
be involved. However, those regional people are involved, but...
We've really tried to give everyone a link.
because when you're doing everything, then everything.
than everything mediocre, nothing's fantastic.
Because--
is that you're splitting too many hairs.
Mm hmm.
Honestly, I think that it was...
was I really tried to make a video.
I truly believe that when I came on board,
It was, Thawn Henderson was managing and
maybe I'm wrong, but before I come up work,
he and Nicole were managing.
most of the deal or the or the
proposals that were happening in the RFPs, whether it's I
of M.
And I think they were spread so thin that everyone...
everyone else was jumping in to help kind of.
help solution and ease the burn a little bit.
And then once I got trained up to where
Nicole, it took a while, right, for Nicole to trust me.
on if I put a proposal together is it.
Is it right? Can Todd and I work through it together?
and I call her now and say, "Hey Todd, it's good with it.
Are you good with it?"
And so I think that it's building up.
that team. I really do think that that before we just didn't have
the right people in the right spots or enough of them.
So then, C-suite, they feel immense pressure right to grow.
So there's almost this micromanagement of life.
I have to help everybody do everything.
You're smiling.
I know that you understand that right there's like a there's a there's a
just an immense pressure to grow.
And so they feel like they have to have their hands.
and everything to make sure it goes right.
But when you're not doing that,
you do that, number one you take the power away from the people
who work so hard to do, to learn and do what they do.
And--
I told Chum, "That's what I'm going to call with."
Nicole Nick Vow, Sean, and...
and Charles.
I'm kind of the background noise.
because I'm listening and I'm observing. So there's a point...
and the very beginning where Charles like, is she immune?
Like does she stay?
anything or does she just sit there and
Sean was like and Nick said you know you have to understand number one.
is intimidating when you have everyone who's been here for so long, right?
She's observing to see how we really like how
this dysfunction rolls out and in three.
like when does when is it appropriate for her to have a
voice like because at some point now I feel like I have more
voice but before that it was what can I even offer?
to this conversation because I
I'm the one that has the least amount of experience.
So, and I've also seen where brand new people come in.
and they just like have diary of the matter.
and they never stop talking and then you're like
What are you even talking about?
If nothing you said, it was a big circle.
I know you want to be heard, but it didn't make sense.
So there's some of that where I think that we had to--
build the right people up.
Now, every time you promote someone,
like now,
I'm over this vertical so then I'll
I'm pulled from Sean's team so now Sean has a backfill.
with CRE on those proposals and that relationship.
and that's a whole other and we haven't made that public
honestly on any social media.
like that because I still support both IFM.
because I have so many relationships on the other side still.
um that we have to get about
And that takes, I mean, when people are brand new, they're like,
like how do you think it really is going to take before you
where I'm comfortable in my role.
And I said, I'm--
I'm sure you're gonna wanna hear me say three to six months,
but probably...
one to two years because there's just so much to learn.
and so many expectations to uphold.
But I think that's where the gap is.
I think that was the...
like once I could, they could trust me.
then Nicole was still involved.
Val could back out a little bit because she has her hands full plenty.
to make sure that the operations are running smoothly, then to be.
involved in every bit we do.
Yeah.
No.
Send him my way so we can...
a conversation on the books with Sean and myself. Sean...
Obviously, his team being the ultimate decision maker,
but we're always looking for
that next part. To be quite honest we're looking
even if it's on a backfill, we're looking to build that sales team up.
So if you have people from that group that
would be fantastic. Just send them our way because we love to.
to see how we build up our team.
'Cause like I said, I do truly.
I think that's the do different right now is that.
We've been building up a team of people to really
We even have what we call sales lead gyms now.
So we have a entire team of like...
new college grads who are hungry, who are doing cold.
but kind of learning the business on we have.
have two that have been here for about a year and they
really stood out, right?
The amount of calls are made.
making some businesses they've brought in relationships they've built.
And so I told Sean I'm like it's time to move them.
on our team now so that we can so they'll get bored.
And we can teach them, really teach them the business, right?
And--
So now we've each of us, he's put one on CB, one for...
me to mentor, which is great because we're kind of building
from within, but we're starting off with someone who's young at home.
hungry and hopefully they don't
always all turn out the way we would hope that they would because
a lot of new college grads, just to be honest, I have two.
college myself they all think they should come out making six figures
and working from home and having a
tea time at 2pm. So you know
It's just the way of the world now, so.
Perfect.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Yeah, yeah.
We can schedule more time though if you can put any.
thing on the book anytime we can always schedule another timeframe too.
[MUSIC]
(chuckles)
Yeah, that would be.
fantastic. So just wondering how logistically how that would work too.
Like say we have Sean or I have a
Maybe just me but working on a big program.
proposal is that like.
You're contracting out work with individuals that...
Is that okay?
Yeah.
Awesome. Now obviously I'm sure I have to
have some type of approval to be able to share.
all the details of our proposal, right?
So I have to...
talk through this with what did that did you and Nicole?
have a good working relationship when you're here too.
She's until.
Yes.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
And our team is smooth.
than it was before.
if you can believe that. So.
Lotsa is, yeah, and Sean.
Goodnight.
(phone ringing)
- Yeah.
Yes, they did.
and she's actually doing a really fantastic job.
So now we have Sean Loxa and Cassie.
So they end.
I mean, like I said, it's a lot more, right?
No matter what, you can put something together and you're like, "This is awesome."
And then you go to your first call and it's like
they want 80 changes and they
then you feel defeated.
I do the same thing.
I build a model, I take it to--
pricing and Todd Cordell like chops it.
like every which way and it looks like diced ham and I'm like
Oh my gosh, I was so proud of this.
But then at the end of the day, also thankful that you do have
a lot of good people like that who can call you who can call out
like the gaps or the you're I say situational blanks.
because I'm so in with this deal or
what I think this client needs. It's nice fruit.
people to be able that aren't as connected.
into it to say, "No, hey, this is from a..."
larger perspective or from my experience here are some things that
that you maybe didn't think about or were putting in or they think of
things, whether it's proposal management or marketing.
or pricing. I think of things all the time that I did.
wasn't even in my purview.
So when I say team, I think that's
That's my leadership style, but that probably
is a little bit of a shift from when you were here.
because I do think that now we have,
we do have a
have more of that.
Everyone has a role.
We all work together obviously but it's
There's definitely some lanes to stay in.
[ Laughter ]
That's a perfect word.
I don't know.
Yes.
Yeah.
your birth.
right?
Yeah, absolutely, absolutely.
And I think--
like I said, logistically, I'd have to--
I'm sure I'd have to have--
approval from C-suite to be able to pull.
someone and also as a consultant to do that.
It sounds fantastic because I know that there are plenty of times, right?
that we are.
We have quick turnarounds too.
Even large proposals, hey we need this in four days.
Right, our team already has 10 other things that are on.
on their burners that they're working through.
So it may be
make sense to have someone like you in your
your position that we can kind of call the troops and say, hey, we
have this happening? Are you able to support this time?
So I think it's a great idea.
I'd love to bring it up to, I say the powers that be
to make sure that this is what we could do, right? But I think it's
I do definitely see a place for it for sure.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Yeah, I don't disagree.
because there is such a high volume of things that are flying.
at them on a daily basis as well.
And some of
them very low priority, very low priority.
revenue versus our high priority quick
growth, RFPs and deals.
But yeah, I definitely, like I said, I definitely see a need for that.
I love the pitch that ideas and Nicole and Sean and
see what they're thinking because ultimately Sean Nicole
it's Sean Nicole and Nick were on board that they can
They can convince Charles of almost anything.
They could spend--
to be honest but it's just
getting picking their brains and see where they
Charles is that what space he's in you gotta pick the good
You gotta pick the good day, fish it.
Yeah, sure. Yeah.
Friday is best usually but yes.
- Right. - Yeah.
Yep, it's been fixed.
I'm glad you set this up.
Thanks for reaching out.
And then I will--
Let's stay in touch.
I'll reach out as soon as I get something.
from the team to see how we could make
this work.
Well thanks. Alright, thanks.
Talk to you soon.
Bye.